[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back to today in chess
World Championship Edition and we're
again as you can see from the open we're
bringing you totally unbiased coverage
as we jump into the heat of battle at
the World Championship we're in round 2
of 12 potential rounds of this epic
match we've been waiting for a while six
months some might say to see this great
American challenger Fabiano Kara wanna
face the reigning king Magnus Carlsen
others could say we've been waiting for
decades to get an American shot at the
grand title and both would be true both
would be truthful statements we have
been waiting for decades and yes we are
watching the World Chess Championship
Game two after an epic opening yesterday
Jennifer Wow seven hours exhausting
thrilling at the same time the first
four hours were totally thrilling and
then it was a grind but we know that
Magnus you can never let your guard down
yeah you can grind you down
he set some really amazing traps but
fabbi we stayed alert throughout and he
held a tough tough hard-earned draw and
the really really good news is he didn't
lose that game that was that was a
victory of sorts for Fatih and I I'm
Jennifer jihadi this is yasser sara long
we are going to be bringing you the
action for the next couple weeks and not
only the World Championship we're also
gonna be talking about some other events
including the Women's World Champion
absolutely that's going on in Russia at
the same time that's right but let's
take a look at the format for our
marquee event for those of you who are
just joining us we're in round two of
potential 12 games unlikely 12 games I
would say but the first player to get
six and a half wins the match we've got
a luxurious three part time control so
as we saw yesterday the games can go up
to seven hours no draw offers before
blacks thirtieth move I don't think that
would happen anyway these players are
here to fight and try to make as much as
they can out of any white absolutely no
question about that and as you say there
are three time controls 100 minutes with
the first four
and then the third time controllers
afternoon 60 and over a million dollars
in the price on the schedule also luxury
as is important for a world championship
match there are two games and then
there's a rest day and we see this
pattern until the end of the match in
which case if it's still split six eggs
we're gonna have a tie breaks a rapid
playoff blitz if necessary all this rest
jazz it's really important I think to
get the players prepared and make sure
that they don't completely burn out I
mean yesterday's battle Wow I'm sure
Fabio is already exhausted hmm but
meanwhile as we look towards the future
we're going to go to grandmaster Maurice
Ashley to look at the past and these
players live ratings over 2018 well 2018
certainly has been a majestic here for
Fabiano Caruana his reigning we know was
meteoric when he won the Singh field cup
with that spectacular score in 2014
he then took a dip for a while and then
slowly but surely started building it up
but this year has been great for him as
has not been so bad for a Magnus either
and we take a look at the graph here as
you see at the top Magnus
he was stratospheric as the number one
rated player of all time he was 28 89
was his live rating but since then it's
very difficult to maintain that rating
he did keep a distance between all his
pursuers but now look at the convergence
as Magnus not a bad year for him not
many losses in fact but all those draws
whenever you lose it's like Chinese
water torture he's just little by little
you're the hit that dippers happen in
the meantime
Bobby's here you see that gigantic dip
is because of his bad result in Tata
Steel but since then he has just simply
surged he won the candidates then won
Greinke then won Norway his type of
first had the Sinquefield Cup and his
good result at the Olympian all that has
brought him now within a stone's throw a
hair's breadth of Magnus Carlsen if he
wins this match even +1 he's going to be
the
number one ranked player on the planet
and you see there that's not gonna be
easy to do because five games Bobby
hasn't won any against Magnus this year
and in fact has lost one and as we saw
yesterday has been pressed in others as
well sink filled Cup he may have lost
also so three games that easily could
have gone the way of the champion but
Olli will +1 for a Magnus will see
whether or not that stays to form in
this event now we should point out a bit
of trivia the seven matches that have
occurred the 12th with 12 games and
since the inception of the 12 game
matches the Challenger has never won
Game two and in fact the champ has gone
three o'the so history does not bode
well for Fabi on this individual game
but we will see whether or not he can
rewrite history and possibly win as this
position is interesting and looks fine
for him Thank You Marie
that's right maurice let's jump in to
the position yes we are and now in about
a halfway mark of both the time control
and the the moot count mm-hmm and I'm
looking at this position it's lots of
trades you see that gorgeous Bishop on
f3 and the rook on b1 so you got to give
magnet some marks for a better piece
play but on the other hand his pawn
structure much worse so who do you go
with I like black I like black because I
love playing against structural
weaknesses after as you know noted in
this exact position Magnus did decided
not to wait to defend this pawn on e5
but instead tried to keep as much
activity for his pieces with the roof
roof b1 attacking the pawn on b7 we did
see the move rook b8 already played I
was I I suppose that the reason that
white it was not worried that Magnus was
not worried about the loss of the pawn
was that in such a situation where I get
to play Queen d8 Jack and pin the black
pieces along the eighth-ranked that's
ample compensation for the pond and
that's why fabbi chose to play the move
rook b8 and I believe
now up-to-date with the players after
Queen d3 if I were in black fabbi shoes
I play Bishop d7 and again I have no
worries about this position whatsoever
for the black player
I like the idea I like the fact that
this Queen is really nice it's a tax the
pawn on c7 and it a five it attacks the
pawn on c3 and part of me even this
Bishop attacks upon an eighth a four
which is pretty relevant because suppose
I tried to move we'd d6 here oh that
that I will hopefully deal with with
open arms I'll embrace with open arms
and what I wanted what I want to say is
that this pawn on d6 is really
susceptible it's really close to blacks
King and it may be that it's beyond your
supply lines to maintain the pawn on d6
well my thought is can i bum rush you
with a5 father by c4 c5 do I have time
to do all that right if you get as you
say the bone rush I like that if you get
the bum's rush and you get to manage to
play moves like a 5 before anything bad
happens towards for you I can imagine it
will be ok rook takes of course as a key
move if you take with a pawn then I
would just continue along with my c4 and
c5 maybe I shouldn't take until I have
to so just like in here a continued c4
instead of Paige continue with the move
c4 right yeah okay that makes a lot of
sense to me as well Jen I like that idea
maybe gonna have to tactically defend
with rook c8 now well yeah I'll step off
the the the pin and let's say if we
trade everything and I still have back
rank issues which would be a key temple
for you right with the Melbourne no
longer winning this no I know I think
it's going to be a pretty easy draws
it's kind of a funny thing that when you
went Queen d6 that I had to actually
play ball with you there I'm I really
think that it's one of those positions
that could it's actually a lot sharper
than you would imagine it to
I mean I'm leaving I'm leaving you in a
situation where you may have to
connected pass Vaughn's person outside
possible but versus a very far outside
passer so I would be surprised if y can
just play Queen d6 and bail out I
thought that black had a little edge at
the moment I'm just gonna say it's about
even but if I had my choice of which
which side I prefer to play I would I
would take black well that makes sense
because it seems like white needs to
find the right
tactical dynamic solution to White's
strategic edge and if they don't they
could end up in trouble right well let's
be clear white has the more active
pieces yeah he doesn't have a strategic
as a strategic inferiority but the
structure yes so he's got to use his
dynamic right possibilities to the
outside whereas blacks moves come where
easy right black and just play b6 rook
c8 Bishop e8 it's it's great right and
like you were looking for ideas of a5
and c4 and timing very very important I
gotta find the right sequence and you
know it's funny because usually people
say the opposite yes especially players
who are just starting out that it's
always easier to play with the active
pieces yeah right man I think that's
more maybe that's more true when there's
a lot more pieces in the board that's
right
White's left it to just a couple is the
cusp of having enough pieces to make the
activity meaningful I've always enjoyed
playing against my opponents structural
pawn weaknesses because it's like
long-term and if you find all the right
moves and you do you know handle the
structural weaknesses and make it draw
more power to you but it's very easy
like a single misstep move could really
see why didn't a lot of trouble in this
game right I don't discount that black
could pull off an upset here let's talk
about a fantasy here yes I could put any
two minor pieces on this board I feel
like I've liked white I could appear a
dark square pair of 95 and it gives us
attacking chances but unfortunately
there
just too many trades for magnets to make
a out of it yes yes and again I mean
there are pawns hanging in the position
the a for pawn the e5 pawn but I know
that Maurice has been keeping a very
close eye on the women's championships
is there in the the there there in the
round of 16 as well and it's it's really
been a thrilling it's a 64 cutter
knockout first of all I said it right
haha see for player knockout we had two
American players and they've both been
eliminated in the round Sabina was
eliminated in the first round
it's a beautiful wizard again and yeah
we will talk about that in a bit we're
actually okay we're actually in the
round of 16 that's gonna be tie breakers
tomorrow and then we'll have our final
lead when we come back on Monday
um but first we have grandmaster Maurice
Ashley to give his thoughts on how we
got here in Carlson Carolina yes of
course the games the game was in
progress when we jumped on and came into
the middle of this and it should be
noted that there was some intriguing at
least one particularly intriguing moment
that occurred in the opening so we see
here of course his Queens gambit
declined position and after Bishop c5
Queen to c2 9 c6 a 3 this is such a
well-known position has been played
countless number of times but this move
rook d1 was answered by rook to d8 and
this is not the most natural move the
popular move here is Bishop back to e7
and that is the by far the most popular
move in the position avoiding any Forks
on before and the like but rook to b8
this move is infrequently seen and white
usually gets an edge out of this
position now Jessie cry Grandmaster in
residence and also a commentator at the
club he was just hanging out and when we
were talking about this position he said
rook d8 what is that we've known since
we were kids that's a bad move and I
said well yeah but it is after all
preparation the guy's been spending six
months preparing for a match
he's 2832 after all and the fact that 92
which is commonly considered the right
the right way to proceed in this
position was not played by Magnus you've
got to think that there's got to be some
preparation here and just he just
insisted no way in the world we're not
gonna see Brooke d8 again and I couldn't
get him off of that off of that idea at
all cuz he just so hated the move rook
to d8 now we will see whether or not
this was indeed a bluff as yes he also
said about the move but this certainly
was not the most popular move in the
position 92 was considered the right way
to go but Bishop e2 avoiding any kind of
preparation is what Magnus did and
that's how we got to this position after
all these trades 86 and another
interesting mobile with this Knight
switching to e7 and the bishop dropping
back and we saw a lot of sharp ideas
happen here after Knight takes takes and
Bishop to e5 this is what actually
caused the structure to be what it was
but just a bit of tension that rook to
d8 move and also the knight maneuver
followed by that trade certainly an
interesting position but was it a bluff
rook d8 no it wasn't a bluff no no no
these players have been preparing
themselves for quite some time and
there's no doubt I have no doubts
whatsoever that rook d8 was deeply
prepared by Fabiano that's what I was
saying I mean it's kind of hard to
believe that he would just play a move
get in this position and say oops
I'm just here and then play the move
rook d8 knowing that that's not the
standard way to play in this position no
and I would just add one thing further
that Fabiano of course has a great rival
here in the United States and Hikaru
Nakamura and this is he carros
bread-and-butter
defense is black so you know he's been
studying the games of Hikaru Nakamura
has been Fabiano and Andy Carl is
probably one of the most experienced
player Maurice this variation is black
absolutely play some sharp razor mcCargo
plays this razor sharp stuff right
sacrifices on d4 Knight lands on d4
right he's five and they five and that
craziness
we've seen that happen a few times in
fact that's from Hikaru what we've been
doing commentary right to see Fabi play
this is to me it seems unusual that it
would make a move that is not the
standard to reply in this position and
not be well prepared and by the way he
was ahead on the clock at the point that
he did it very quickly he was ahead on
the clock as Magnus started slowing down
dramatically so to deal with this
opening surprise so I would say
successfully he won the opening battle
he came out of it with this position
that we see now on the board as we jump
ahead to this position and I mean oh
this this is actually not the game
position let me refresh my board here it
is this is what we have is the game
position and it looks like things are
getting interesting again with this move
a five on the board okay so instead of
Queen b6 a5 immediately with some some
of the ideas that we were looking at
with Queen d6 perhaps being still in the
air right because in both games black
coffee heads right well exactly opening
battle even for yesterday's game and
today's game yeah and we had a move that
I think we had a move after 85 did we
Chen was it Bishop c6 I'm not sure I
wasn't sure we saw it in this position
instead of the move Queen d6 a5 was the
choice of Magnus and it's happy to play
still yeah it's still poppy to play I
believe no Queen d6
a5 well similar ideas to what we were
looking at white would like now to play
Queen d6 now the question for me is what
about the bishop c6 seems like a move
that really helps you getting rid of the
weak points the pawn on v7 and the
bishop on d7 right yes she was kind of
defending everything whereas now if I
were to play let's just say I started
trading things with Bishop Dixie sake
and let me just pause here for a second
because I think everybody would play
Queen takes c6 recapture in a blitz game
without too much thought the reason I
would pause a moment is because again
these pawns are hanging and it's
actually white
it's King why does not have lift in the
position so if I capture with the pawn
and let's just continue with the line
for a moment well trade we're now in a
straight Queen ending but the e pawn is
on pre there's a double threat in the
position I want to say in Black's favor
Abby's threatening to grab upon but oh
it's not threatening give checkmate
sorry I better make looked here if I'm
white but the nice thing about this
position is that at least white has the
potential to if you get a too much
counter play as black I know that that
pawn is so advanced on a 5-2 are always
gonna have to keep an eye on the a7 pawn
so I'm kind of envisioning situations
where even if you were to get e5 and c3
if I can get a 7 and I'm gonna be
totally you you'll be fine so I agree
but I think it's it's a position where
blacks extremely comfortable blacks not
having any issues at all now again at
this moment I'm saying beats b7 takes c6
is a serious recapture as is the move
Queen takes c6 who do you think it
should be who's the player trying to
make the draw here I'm saying it's white
because of this structure you know I
hate that question yeah a good draw I
hate that question who's trying to make
a draw these two guys are so close in
ability the technical prowess of Magnus
Carlsen is so high is that black has no
problems in this position structure is
perfect the Brooklyn b8 is just
temporary right the pressure on b7
irrelevant it's not going to cause any
problems for black whatsoever so this
position is all about those white
weaknesses
however those pawns do control some
space and it's not so easy just to
create play as black a couple of precise
moves by white should equalize the game
and to me I don't see Magnus losing this
it would be amazed
yeah I think it'll be a shocker to see
magnus carlsen loses position with the
white pieces this game looks like it
should be a draw but that said it's not
black who's worried at all in this big
tree of swords for fabbi been watching
at home there's still a lot here of
course I mean it's just the reason that
we say it's probably gonna be drawn is
because we're talking about the two very
best players in the world you gonna find
those ideas and and that Fabi I mean
first of all your B takes c6 move is not
the type of move the most amateurs would
look at me exactly it's all about
privilege activity over structure right
and you were talking about the structure
but it's just ingrained in your brain
that activity is also important but I
had this issue I actually had an
oversight as what I wanted to say I was
looking at b7 takes c6 but quite
seriously because in my mind's eye I had
two threats
I had the threat of Queen takes e5 and
the threat of Queen b1
checkmate only when I actually got to
this position I I realized that the be
ones that the square is actually covered
and so after something right now for for
example and you can deal with you deal
with both my quote threats it's going to
be a drug I could just play Micah
consider playing Queen well after Queen
takes c6 we have to look at the Queen b6
move right Queen d6 again yeah I mean
the reality is he can he can always
trade him ran skiing over
yeah and that then white will be
scrambling to defend that D pawn
maybe he began his pawn down a c5 he
might be able to maneuver that
successfully but black I don't think
black is going to be his worst case
black can always just bail out with rook
c8 rook takes c3 and a lot of trades
well first the Kings gonna end up on d7
that's gonna be fact number one the
Kings gonna end up over there your kings
not fast you're gonna have to use those
pawns
then at the right moment as you said you
and the rook will go to c8 that'll be a
challenge so I agree with you yeah do
you talk about a victory of sorts when
you're playing a match every white is
like a serve in tennis sure and if some
if you can block the serve and say okay
that was no problem you
today you made me suffer I had the white
pieces and you made me suffer today you
had the white pieces and I nullify you
completely nothing say in fact I'm the
one who's thinking about something and
you're the one who's thinking about a
drawer that's a little bit of a
frustration factor for the guy with the
white pieces and we saw this Apple with
Magnus when he played his last match
against Kuryakin he got frustrated when
he couldn't land blows and then other
positions he wasn't doing anything
and then suddenly he lost the game so as
far as Fabi is concerned if he could
just walk out of here after suffering
yesterday walk out with a nice drug get
a nice rest day and in the meantime his
seconds are shoring up the opening for
two days from now right and he's gonna
feel pretty good about himself so that's
where that that's a success already so
if he's got the draw in the pocket he'll
keep it he'll try a little something
today will he try to torture Magnus the
way Magnus tortured him yesterday it
doesn't feel like there's enough in this
position to make that happen but if he
can he will he'll just keep playing a
few moves to see what happens maybe
that's why he's hesitating over the move
Bishop to see sick to see there's any
more juice in the position to use but he
probably is gonna have to settle on
something like that quite shortly mmm
very good and also we're gonna have a
very special guest Jennifer that's right
bruce pandolfini Fabiano Cara Juana's
first trainer he's gonna be coming up
here on the live show and you know
whenever I think of bruce pandolfini and
bobby i can't help to think about that
in New York or photograph of both of
them playing out with the Umbrella
Washington Square Park and the
recreation of it uh-huh
many years later I was an elite player I
I see Bruce pandolfini
I always think searching for bobby
fisher' and Josh Waitzkin Levine II was
also well your best friend Josh Waitzkin
Maurice
Bruce was Josh Waitzkin strain there too
that's right and you know the funny
thing is when I when I'm thinking of
some of those scenes from the Hollywood
movie based on searching for Bobby
Fischer by John by Josh Lincoln's dad
Fred yeah now I'm thinking of them and
I'm thinking of like Bobby right yes
because in a sense he is yeah as Josh
was going to be the new Bobby Fischer
that's right
article said searching for bobby fisher'
us finds Bobby correct that's exactly
what has happened now what you're going
to do Maurice is to show us some of the
ladies games soon soon I know your your
because I know there was a huge result
that stefanova came back she had lost
the first game but she won against honor
right there
one of the most anticipated matches of
that round of 16 was certainly former
women's world champion Antoinetta
stefanova precisely out of musici
that's not actually the highest rated on
the live reading list in in that match
in the entire tournament exactly
literally like a point between them
excellent and today stefana that came
back to even the score so now we
literally see two of the hugest
favorites in the tournament going to be
playing rapid playoff tomorrow oh boy so
that's a really big one and speaking of
the Musa chooks
Maria Musa Chuuk already qualified she's
made it into the rod of lead aids all
right pretty crazy that we might have to
Musa chokes in the Elite Eight but first
Ana's gonna have to strike back again
stefanova because today it was
Antoinetta who got the best of her and
maurice with some key games from the
women's and the results as well we
should point out the complete results as
we have around a 16 so just eight
results to review and first of all the
women's world champion jewel engine
playing fantastic chess so far we noted
that she did defeat America's own arena
crush to move on to this round but then
again defeating her own country woman
Jam oh and she is comfortably in to the
round of 8 we also have some great
matches as you see there go Nina who was
upset yesterday in her match and now we
see the bottom half but all these show a
lot of ties one one that is specifically
what we want to point out that only one
other player as you mentioned has gone
on
and that is Maria musici going on so two
players we're talking about six playoffs
tomorrow six of them to see who hosts in
the round of 8 these are all knockouts
so tremendously exciting round to be
sure incredible play contentious and you
just got to imagine all the nervous
tension every day every game counts
every single day and then knockouts six
of them and those are believable rapid
knockouts or the Blitz they're rapid for
you if you guys are up and depends on
where you are in the world because there
are 10 hours ahead of us watch those
games but you can only imagine how
exciting that is going to be I'd like to
take a look at a couple of the positions
from the games we did talk about you
engine she just made her draw she said
no problem I'm gonna be good in this
position this game between stefanova and
Musa took this was a wild affair but in
the end it came down to an endgame
and she was able to melt this end game
with her extra material here this you
see this maneuver of rook takes before
this extra pawn was enough in this game
this game wasn't actually too wild an
attacking game in this one on the part
of Maria Moseley choke you see the young
Iranian Mabini
Allen Assam she is definitely got
everybody looking at her only 18 years
old
definitely a talented young player that
though talent is one thing experience is
another and Maria Musa took showed what
she had another game that was drawn this
is a big time matchup by the way
Katarina Londo she has been a great
player for a long time as has the other
vet Natalia Pargo Nina
they drew both their games so this is a
big time matchup going into what who
knows who's gonna win people might give
the nod to Katarina a little higher
rated but don't count out the veteran
probably Nina definitely showed that she
can fight with the best of them this
matchup is the one I was talked about
with go Nina go Nina is clearly the
favorite against the young was Becky who
I will dare you to tell me how to
pronounce this name of hers that has got
it has good work banking tour tahor you
know
that's as good as I'm gonna get a lot of
syllables and a lot of consonants in
there by the way doesn't matter as she
won her first game but go Nina would the
big comeback as you see here able to
even the score to take this one to a tie
break again if I go down on the screen
this one was a draw this matchup but
another good matchup by the way elating
knee who is one of the Chinese women who
won the Olympia gold this year against
ELISA gallium Oba who is also a strong
Russian player they have drawn both
their games and they're going on as well
and finally I think I have just a couple
more this end game castaigne against
Harika drona volley another big I mean
any one of these women could win the
title this is how good they're this
kseniya has already won the title in
fact very strong players Harika from
india fantastic talent we'll see how
that one shakes up that'll be great to
watch and now finally we go to another
one
Abdul Malik she is so town she's played
here in st. Louis she hits people hard
and she also played in the world open
and had a fantastic result there I have
my eye on her as a future talent and
future challenger and she's got the
attitude - she's got the swag she just
calm like let's get it done
well she got it done in this game and
she had to and she was able to win
against the young play polish player
yolanta
is on Watzke that's gonna be another
great matchup as they fight it out in
the Battle of all these women for the
for the possibility of going to the
round of 8 it should be extremely
exciting tomorrow and it'll be a rest
day for us so we'll be of course
checking into all the results we'll let
you know everything in a couple of days
but the women's world champion is
absolutely heating up it really is a
thrilling competition in about Abdul
Malik gosh she's got the best scare -
there is terrifying
I gotta see the girls a real killer
she's got swag I mean she's definitely
shows she's not afraid of anybody that's
the attitude when you see her at a board
you see her pictures everything and and
even the way she just handles herself
although
she gets interviewed she's the most
pleasant interview in the world
she's just calm collected funny but on
the board you better come with the moves
she did an event it's true because I I
see those death stares but she did an
event with Anna Rudolph in a nightclub
yeah in Oslo I believe I can
double-check of that but it was like a
fun chess chess event at a nightclub
okay so they were like playing blitz
while like people were club okay about
what you didn't have a desk there I
guess not I'm not at the club but
speaking of some photos we're gonna have
a nice little montage of photos for our
viewers courtesy of my client of chess
calm and we're gonna show the what the
London see the hand obviously in round 2
because around 1 rather it was gonna
have some kind of nice photo shop that's
a real picture
no really there's a poppies that's there
this is more calm I wouldn't call it
quite intimidating it's gonna work on me
bed doesn't have any deaths there he's
done pretty well for himself
exactly now there's the California cool
that's what were you used to with Magnus
these guys have you know more like calm
demeanors at the board then for instance
of course a I garry kasparov go that was
it death yeah summer one that really is
a balloon than the thing it's like yeah
I think that's part of their like
marketing angle yeah with like texting
in their app okay but
I've heard idea Rogers wrote a report
for the u.s. chess Federation's website
that I just posted last night and she
said that the venue was not as bad as he
expected in some ways because he thought
it would be overcrowded but it turned
out that the crowds were relatively well
maintained the one problem was the press
area there's so much interesting as
journalism these days you really need a
big comfortable room for the prime media
center was too small there was 35 seats
for a hundred and twenty accredited
journalists at the start of the there's
so many journalists covering chats and
there's there are so many great writers
now talking and writing about chess
commenting on it so of course again of
course Mike and it's just a really great
age with up so we got all so right so so
in the Ian's report how did he say that
the organizers handled this overwhelming
turnout of journalists I think he was at
first a little concerned because there
apparently there was a little bit of
stop and a lot of the people who had
registered previously had to reread her
okay all of their press credentials okay
so it's turned out to be a bit of a mess
but he said they were able to like
resolve it for the most part that
everybody who needed to get in and get
their photos of a Fabien Magnus did okay
very very important yeah but no oh well
I'll keep you posted as he continues to
report from London certainly well
wonderful well let's get to what has
happened in the game between Fabian
Magnus when we have left it we've just
seen this moves queen d3 Bishop d7 all
very standard moves a5 which we had
mentioned in Bishop c6 neutralizing the
diagonal we will mainly focus gin on
potential captures and then right away
was choice but so the negative of this
move is that after Queen d6 pawn d6 now
a black has the opportunity
you week and white spot structure even
further which takes f3 bit then I've
kind of given lift to white exactly side
you we've gained a tempo in a way
because our Qingdao is a little bit
faster also it could potentially go to
g2 g3 f4 right but the question is after
after that happens what's going on with
the c4 c5 push how fast are we right
it's all about the Tempe indeed so let
me start with the move rook d8 it wants
I don't want to resolve this tension
quite yet
I'd like you to invest a tempo with the
move a5 a6 before forcing me to capture
on f3 dr. so after a 6 it looks like
there's a lot of variations of poultry
insect just like lots and lots of trades
right yes exactly
I don't even know I don't want to go for
that one I think after a 6 Bishop takes
up 3 I could even play takes on b7 to be
cute but that would maybe that's a
little bit excessive yeah I do
I do recapture and I got the capture and
like you say since there's no pawn on f3
in this variation White has to actually
respect the back rank unnecessary after
Bishop takes f3 instead you could simply
play G takes f 3 yeah and then rookie 6
Brooke b7 right or in the I don't think
I I don't want to really well maybe I do
I think I would probably just play chill
okay maybe I should come up with
something different here okay like one
thing if you just want to bail out and
say okay let's make a draw together
let's be friends we can go take stakes
King takes King f1 takes now you can
give a check and now after this move you
win your pawn back because this is a
double attack
against this is this guy and I think
there's going to be a massive
liquidation and everybody can be happy
and go home that's right get some fish
and chips
fish and chips there you go okay but
yeah I think that we are gonna see
something like this in this game it's a
situation of how how they do it and
whether there's any tricks in the
position that one player will try to go
for it looks like we do have a couple
moves doing let me except three and G
takes f three you wanted to play look D
eight firm yeah Abby go for the Bishop a
three trade at once
yeah don't you imagine he's gonna play
like king over and try to go after that
Paul and King f8 exactly at the moment
the pawn I'm b7 is nicely defended I
wasn't I was having a very interesting
thing for a discussion with myself about
this funny King and pawn in game now
before just imagine a situation like
this who would you guess is winning this
king of the pond in game unfortunately
the little mercury on the on the left
side of the board gave it away yeah
because what's too quick of course King
f1 of course I did
but the idea is that these two pawns on
d7 and c6 are really really strong
except blacks now has bridesmaids on the
Queen side and the King side and so also
I'm just so fast right in that
particular position of 85 I just can't
even get into the square of the pot oh
yeah oh that was the okay okay I was
thinking that that black was going ooh
maybe I just pushed too fast black
should make a pass whoops we're okay
black should make a pass pawn on the
Kings side and the Queen side so he
should be going like f5 g5 and making a
passer and this endgame is so sharp what
you just put on the booth yeah it's not
even funny
this one White has to compete against
blacks passport on the other side ones
actually help they don't miss ya there's
no nerds yeah yeah it's harder it's not
easy to get the passport against these
guys right you're gonna have to
sacrifice something actually to get the
past party right but how do you execute
I mean this is sharp and the fact that
the engines already bailing out and
saying equal zero zero is like what
because obviously the 8-ball is not
going anywhere
White's threatening white the black king
will go and see six in this position so
white will not be able to get to b5 and
just collect the pawn and is not gonna
must be so easy to advance there but for
white to maintain the balances may have
to sacrifice with d7 and then play king
b5 take the pawn right try to make his
pawn work will he get back in time I
mean this one this one could take us
literally an hour to analyze right crazy
I just thought it was an interesting and
wild king of pot and game is completely
wild and that's the kind of position
that you know we we as players we
normally you're like okay let's learn
from this position as I said and analyze
and analyze and analyze is it forced our
take this idea King FA where we
anticipate c4 being force there's no
real judgment about that one right
and essentially what white wants to do
is play see five and a six so I was
looking at King e8 c5 now if I have a
choice please let me know
I went King d7 and I went a sex is X
essentially yeah because if you get to
play king c6 my pawns are going to be
quite vulnerable to capture so I thought
I have to be very consequential in
forcing so I played a six now the
clinton this is maybe a controversial
move you black doesn't necessarily have
to play the move the king to c6 i mean
he may be able to just play b6 as well
like for example
a situation like this could just well
and in a kind of a draw maybe some
suffering for life
maybe so what about what if why just
tries to hold the stasis how are you
make progress like suppose instead of
instead of a six I play rook c1 okay and
so I see you're gonna play King c6 which
is for sure okay and then what like but
what's your next strategy if I start
moving I would love to activate my grew
up don't ask me exactly how I want my
king yeah I guess I want to activate my
rook somehow with E 5 and maybe f5 and
g5 somehow get my rook going and I need
to get my cake into the game should I go
buy a g2 or f1 oh there's one other
thing you have to be careful about Jen
don't forget I could play rook to d8
rook to d7 and then go pawn hunting with
king b5 I was hoping I would always be
able to bail out with like a c6 or a6 at
the right moment
whirlwind of fun or work be one checking
c5 or b7 ok so let's give it up okay
should you like to play King G - yeah
and then I'll go do it because I'm a
pawn rotten King Jesus or any said ok
trying to make some progress King f4 ok
so I'm a pawn grabber I want to take
this little just play key 5 + C 6 and
rook takes c6 ok I'd have fun that way
so you'd protect the pawn so that after
I grab your pawn you want to go here
here and you're just in time you're next
hold on sorry I have an idea I love
these things that when they happen okay
could you back up a second of course
what do you put it back on c5 the palm
and if I play rook e1 rook e1
oh yeah cut him off cut him off at the
pass yeah and I'm threatening to
sacrifice and get to fast one no what
are you dead oh yeah you have nothing to
more time or well just say yeah it's
dead you won't say that I have more
lives than a cat
I play for f4 f5 again I gotta get the
d5 square peg your dad it's live okay
it's legal it's a legal move you're
you're still I don't know what Black's
gonna run out of moves can black ever
play rug d8 that's the question she's
six stopping at five I'm not so happy
about giving up the square for a second
okay five ok the engines going nuts for
some reason why five now okay I'll take
that guy and now I'm okay you want to
play King d5 here Jen was my idea to
play King d5 and c6 and just try to
channel better yep you just weigh 85
rook okay what is the threat okay one
and then take on a seven King defied me
dancing after King d5 right the threat
is to British player gate one and then
take the pawn on a seven and then take
the pawn on b7 and it's likely crashes -
and that's a great that belongs in like
a lesson for kids about cutting off
patience patience any meaning to cut off
the king I was trying to psych on b7
both things the same time as well nice
benefit there are no he went from zero
to hero you got to slow that thing down
so we'll just we'll just go right Mary 5
okay I was greedy I have to confess I
was greedy and I went for this pawn
immediately and it's f6 it is that looks
way better way better five before that
know you like f6 better look like a play
for H forward F okay I mean the rook is
actually very very defensive minded but
okay again this is a pawn so can you for
now
King e4 no yeah okay and well in for a
penny in for a pound
not King D for King D oh my king might
get kicked cut off again yep same
problem Oh every time I want to take a
pawn a move like King c4 could really
hurt yep so those pawns
what mother protected
thank you bad their charm what it is it
took too long time it took too long for
you to win this pawn the way you were
trying to win it with the rook da rugby
several new birth
I wanted to have my cake and eating
right you wanted everything but then I
came came up so quickly that it was able
to help out in this defense this way of
playing King G 2 G 3 F 4 e 4 d 4 that's
5 moves
f 1 e 2 d 3 d 4 is only 4 so did I
choose the wrong path the thing is by
going to G 3 I forced you to spend a
tempo on f6 but actually was Loesser to
d4 and that was a good good yeah I think
how can we update the current position
by the way I think they Maresa they have
reached our end game no they because
probably improved on the position ok we
got it
he played KF 8 c4 yes well we were where
we were here King f8 c4 King e8 I think
I've transposed into our always very
important move so here King e8 alright
he played a6 immediately ok and I'm
gonna turn off my auto update so that
God should analyze computer insist for
it alright let's get you out of here
first
and now I'll come back alright ok now I
should be able to control the board so
King EA a 6 was played right here a 6 b
6 mmhmm and then c5 king D 7 c b6 so we
were in a different position now a 7
rookie and this like happened very very
fast this is a position that I was
analyzing before we got caught up in
that position and this one is better for
black no question but white can bail out
into several drawn end games without any
effort right this one vs. is going super
fast into a draw this pawn is difficult
for black to corral this pawn because
it's not easy just to bring the
recommend just an e5 King e5 King e6 and
rook d7 as
threat but and he has in fact played the
movie five after kingi - so this is on
the board he plans to play here it's all
black for choice in terms of having the
advantage over this what it looks like
optically a good pass pawn which clearly
it is not but we don't expect this to be
anything but a draw as Magnus has
confidently gone to this ending saying I
know what I'm doing so we do have this
current position on the board with E 5
pen yes ok very good
and the times Jennifer Lee irrelevant
they can't really playing a pretty good
tempo yes his increment Bobby's been
faster the madness of this game oh that
goes to show the pally its preparation'
right it was almost like he had a
40-minute edge coming out of the opening
advantage on on the clock so what can I
say this is just an equal ending yeah
equal and not that exciting but I would
like to go over other we are today in
chess so we go over a lot of happenings
in the world of chess and we have two
nice tournaments that are taking place
here in the club as we speak this
they've gone on to now round 6 is where
they're going to be entering and but
it's two sections a and B at the top
right now we have Cuban Grandmaster
casino Perez who is leading the a group
with Jeffrey's young young Jeffrey Zhong
of the US right behind him and the B
group Nicholas Teodoro of Greece is
leading and man we were recalled
yesterday yeah as you and I were
watching this incredible analysis from
this game and I want to show you just
this piece of it that will blow your
mind I knew it blew ours the way this
game went Knight g4 we first of all look
at the board I mean the board is
completely insane this night on b3 black
is up upon crazy position but 94
highlighting this night as a weakness
and black decided to play Knight takes
on g4 sacrificing two pieces sacrificing
the Queen for two pieces knowing that he
had a pawn in his pocket think he was
going to get great play his knight is in
a f2 this fight is coming back to
for he hopes maybe to round up this pawn
but is basically his character ploy that
he was counting on and white played this
insane shot d6 in the position I
remember white has a queen for two
pieces after Bishop takes through two he
took on c7 now black has three pieces
for that Queen but the problem is the
monstrosity sitting on the c7 square
after rook takes d1 rook takes and
Bishop back now he has his three pieces
suddenly rook to d8 and this pawn is a
monster mate threats on the back row
black played rook to f8
only to be one of the most incredible
moves and sequences you'll ever see in
your life the move Queen to e4 placing
the Queen on praise by this bishop all
about trying to Queen this pawn after
Bishop takes f2 check he couldn't play
King f1 because of Knight to d2 for King
suddenly his king and queen and forcing
this piece back out of the game and
black will be able to defend instead
however he just played the cool and he
had seen it all King to g2 not only the
hanging piece the south pin as well but
it doesn't matter because it's still all
about the pawn after takes and takes
nothing at all to do about the c7 part
white black actually played rook takes
he was so impressed by his opponents
boos he actually played rotates and C
takes D 8 with the rook mate ending the
game absolutely amazing sequence
happening just shows you how incredible
chess can be by the way Nikolas is only
an IM mmm he's a 2525 I am expect him to
get his GM title quite soon Greece
certainly looking forward to seeing
another GM in their ranks what an
amazing game Thank You Maurice it really
was an amazing game again that that game
is from a tournament taking place here
at the st. Louis chess club the winner
chess classic and you can follow all the
games on us chess champs dot-com or
gamma tree yeah that's right they've got
Grandmaster Jessie cry and
Bensimon from st. Louis chess club a
YouTube channel so be sure to tune in I
mean there's just some incredible
players well it's just so much happening
in the world of chess these days it's
just amazing young stars you know we've
been talking about 18 year olds and the
Women's World Championship but we've got
our best 18 girls in the US chess right
here Jeffrey Zhang and Sam Savion
exactly we're playing right now in this
very game from the B group by the way
that's right yeah B group yeah
insane well we as we get prepared for
our first breaker today we do want to
remind our viewers that we are going to
have a special guests featured guess
everybody's friend bruce pandolfini
jennifer that's right we will be on the
line with Kendall Feeny as we see Game
two of the World Chess Championship
match between Carlson and Kara wanna
continue to build in its tension and
we'll be back
[Music]
you may have heard about st. Louis's
world-class museums art history science
even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by it
[Music]
whose kids it is st. Loup is always
explode he delighted the world chess
Hall of Fame in st. Louis is nothing
you'd expect and everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the same Louis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in chess
world championship edition where we have
Fabiano Carolina now in round 2 putting
the pressure on Magnus Carlsen as it's
almost an inverse of yesterday a reverse
where Magnus was making Bobby suffer
with the black pieces it's probably
gonna do the exact same thing to Magnus
today or do you think Magnus is an
escape a lot sooner both I think it's
gonna be a draw but I think that fabbi
is more than happy to return the favor
that he suffered through in game 1 as he
does have an edge of an extra pawn in a
real component in game distribution
exactly this for freaking 4 against
broken 3 and now working 3 against
working 2 so we have mirror image of
yesterday the lock once again up a pawn
in a rook and pawn ending exactly that's
what you would actually expect from
players at this level they're such
refined players you will not expect to
see like the spectacular crazy wild game
I just showed you before the break
meaning attacks generally don't occur at
this level usually it's some very
precise in gameplay that you're gonna
have to figure out because the player
usually bails out when he sees that
positions under so much pressure that's
the art of defense at the 2800 level
they see the attack coming they say wait
a minute I gotta shut that down long in
advance I'll give you a pawn for some
kind of ending that maybe I can draw and
so you'll see a lot of these don't don't
be surprised if you see maybe 6 or 7
Rick or pawn rook and pawn endings at
this very high level that's the kind of
thing that happens with the white pieces
yes I know that's been the problem acid
it I mean the player with the white
pieces has just found themselves and in
a disadvantage now the strange part
about today's game was that not only did
Magnus not achieve anything with white
he really did it in slow motion as well
it was like he was the one
who was at the board surprised by the
position and he seemed to be spending a
lot of time spinning his wheels and
getting no air Jen well you know please
into this whole question of pregame
preparation yesterday they played a
fantastic clip on today in chess about
Fabiano Carolina's preparation before
the match how it wasn't just all about
openings but it's also about other
elements but I think one thing about
preparation is players spend a lot of
time on black yes they do sometimes you
know there's more at stake you can get
blown off the board with the black
pieces exactly they want to make sure
they're covered up and there's no
accidents that's right sometimes they by
comparison they run out of time to go
over every potential opening with the
white piece it's like you don't know
whether magnets of complaint Sicilian or
the Berlin so of course they put lots of
work in but I think what you're seeing
these first two games is great
preparation with black great conceptions
with black right and nothing really is
being shown with white like yesterday's
F for novelty by fabbi with just natural
play the novelty was defanged very
easily and then suddenly black was
simply better but it also transposed
into known lines until that g5 which was
really the new novelty from that board
position that board position had been
seen before and his idea of g5 where 96
was the new idea and I think now that's
white if you go into this kind of
formation you're gonna say what am I
gonna talk about what Magnus and he's
almost shut down the line
my old trainer Gregory Qaeda naw who
helped me on my path to becoming a
grandmaster many years ago he told me
something very significant and I'll
never forget the words he used he said
nowadays white has nothing and black is
equalizing everywhere and our we were
brought up in the idea you've got white
you should get some kind of small pole
some kind of edge that's but the way
that used to happen of course white
press white press maybe even sacrifice
the pawn for initiative and was able to
make trouble for black nowadays with
computers black goes okay is this
sacrifice correct and they put it in the
computer the computer goes no you just
play this this and this the positions
equal there's nothing here there is
knowing
and that's the problem that players with
white face now is that they can they're
they're not playing against their
opponent they're playing against a
computer and they can't enjoy sacrifice
because both sides know that the
sacrifice is dubious
and so that edge white used to just
expect just about no longer exists in
any of the classical openings which are
well founded on great principles so
that's the challenge they face
Magnus usually resolves this issue by
avoiding theoretical battles he likes to
get into any kind of position he's not
looking for the edge he's just looking
for a playable position that has some
kind of durability that yes we can sit
here and play 30 40 50 moves Nazi
liquidation in 2530 that becomes too
easy for black to do that's what he
usually does so I don't expect Magnus to
go after Fabi with the white pieces and
I was making to look for any big edge he
just wants a sustainable position that
maybe he can outmaneuver Fabi in the
middle game and then eventually in the
endgame good point I mean it's all about
getting those playable positions and at
the very highest level it is very hard
to get the playable position so to speak
now Maurice if I can put you on the spot
in terms of this exact position I'm
playing in the millionaire open it's the
last round and I got to I have to win
this position with black if in your mind
how where is there is there a way I
could trick your up my opponent here
with the black pieces and does fabbi
have any chances whatsoever I would say
you just take your second place and be
happy well I I mean I was hoping that
you you would you would go for the e3
and go King g3 ideas remember yesterday
we're trying to get the two connected
passed pawns for Magnus that might have
won him the game so here I'm thinking
that if I'm in in fabbi shoes I want to
play for an e3 you just get it I can't
get it why not how what are you how do
you gate well okay he played what g6 so
let's say we go rook a seven right and
now I go III how come I can't get it
so my idea is is that if you take I want
to play King g3 and take this pawn so
that I can have the two connected
Passport yeah we're not using you know
of course not
so I have I have a couple of ways to
play but I'm gonna play my in just like
instinctive response okay
kingi to king actually my big my most
instinctive response with either okay
for work f7 so I mean I lied I lied when
I said instinctive response but I'm
gonna play one that I think neutralizes
everything I'm gonna play Cajun King - E
- mmm-hmm okay so now rogue g2 is met by
Rho K for check let's point that out
that's annoying that that word after
rook g2 accomplishes nothing rook check
will force my king away from the pond so
that King takes III ends all he efforts
just thrown away exactly so you went key
sorry you ain't need to and now I'm
threatening to take your palm no I'm
gonna check excuse me I'm right now
you're sending the same react this is
the reader check I'm threatened right so
it looks like with your pawn now under
attack twice because I have two separate
checks to deal with you have to take me
on f2 now right which lets force and if
I play King takes then what do you do
you can't believe me three because I
have a check and when you wrote write to
me this feels like a double mistake ask
where it's one of those things that in
order to win the game for black you mean
white might need to make a couple of our
cooperative like really probably
cooperative right right I follow up the
mistake with another mistake and keep on
a roll and on a roll and so and so on
yeah okay fair enough
well also cuz work out seven check also
seemed okay pushing your king to g5 then
maybe I can pick on e3 right and again
draw but rupee for was actually Magnus's
choice stopping any of that business
directly no III zone a shocker he has
other ways to draw only moves yet this
reminds me of yesterday
blacks got zip and blacks gonna look
around
and see what he can do and try to
torture the guy but he's got zip but I
gotta give him a got some real credit
cuz yesterday he did have some really
ooh
cruel traps that he said and they
avoided them there were some really
brilliant brilliant ones now I don't
think that'd be will be able to
construct some of those really hidden
gems that Magnus managed yesterday that
was remarkable I thought it was really
easily drawn the Magnus found some ways
of making Paddy's life awkward and there
he is and I wonder what yeah
and I'm hearing that it is indeed a draw
because I was wondering though what is
going through fabi's mind in this
position will he try to torture Magnus
but it just seems random this kind of
position seems random to try to torture
him and the fact that they have drawn
the first two games both 12:04 Fabi
this was an easy draw for him this is so
effortless and that that's a good
feeling going into the rest day knowing
that you now get your chance on how to
hit the guy back we said like the right
pieces on Monday but again it's it's
just a toss-up it's going to be a
terrific fight and we're seeing that
these players this game to me showed
just how even they are mmm because
probably just did his thing and settle
them all down well there we have it
we've got two draws in the World
Championship so we're at it's 1:1 our
show we're gonna continue as we get
bruce pandolfini on the line and also
speculate how this bodes for the rest of
the match as we have in the second hour
so don't go away we don't go away but we
have what I was gonna say yes I actually
like this decision not to grind this out
cuz it's pretty clear back it's gonna
draw this yes I'm imagining favi right
now it's probably about 6 p.m. in London
right now 6:30 more or less you know he
needs to start he's got it he's got like
almost what is it 48 hours or almost 48
hours like 42 hours until he has to play
this game three against magnus carlsen
I predicted game three was gonna be the
first decisive game of the map aha you
want him to get arrested and the choice
of battery no no we need to try
something different that's you know it's
so strategic cuz in that game what
happened was like it was actually a
Magnus's masterful genius strategic
ideas they gave him the edge on the
surface it looked okay for Fabia well
let's just talk quickly between
ourselves for games wanted to for me
it's always been a feeling out process
right one of primary openings gonna be
what are the primary defense is going to
be am i in good shape do I feel myself
is my head working get rid of the first
jitters you know this is a million euro
event so was it a good thing these two
draws good start for the match I think
it was a good start for the match for
both players I not just say we had the
two draws that's normal between them
most of their games ended draws look
okay be blood most of the games ending
draws Magnus had his chance that first
game would be the one that Magnus is
kicking himself and saying I could be up
right now good point right but otherwise
that the two draws would be a very
normal result for the beginning of a
match in fact I believe is the last five
matches have ended four of them have
ended in two draws to start these twelve
game matches so it's pretty normal to
see that happen very good and Jennifer
we do have our guest that's right we
have Bruce pandal Feeney on the line
first coach of Fabiano Cara wanna now
he's watching him in the biggest stage
of chess welcome to the show Bruce
thanks for joining us how are you doing
very great Bruce Bruce we've been
buddies for 30 plus years been bring up
the number yeah in a while of course we
you you gave me my first job coach coach
as a chess player back with the raging
rooks in Harlem we were doing that that
chess program in New York
city with American chess foundation
which now is the chest in the Schools
program exactly I knew you'd be great
thank you very much I appreciate that
endorsement and the work we did together
now of course you are Bobby's first
trainer it's hard to say you see talent
right away but did you see talent right
away
oh yes very definitely I couldn't have
predicted this of course but it was
clearly he just loved Chuck so much and
very focused and do all kinds of things
in his head right away
and you're welcome tipped off if you
watch a child gifted child aboard first
blowing chest and getting into it
there's a lot of arm movement a lot of
the pent is focused I move my industry
that Fabiano right away and of course
chest being a game spatial relations
you're thinking is reflected in that
you're the movement of your eyes so that
was pretty obvious he was also it was
also obvious that he was a fighter he's
very determined and he'd want to play
positions out there was and prove that
he could hold I used to try to instill
in him the motto pilot or fight light
spots Bennett fight like popular and I
think we can see that in him now he
fights he gave us a heroic defense
yesterday and he was certainly pushing
it today well he's up against the chess
genius so hopefully things will turn his
way now he's missed a cool calm Bruce we
know a lot of times the young ends they
could be a little bit bratty sometimes a
little chess kids did did he how did the
Aqua knee lost games was he always this
cool I think so he seemed pretty
unemotional he didn't cry a lot you know
talented kids when they lose they get
all upset many of them Christ
normal Bobby I don't didn't do that well
he did only a couple of times he was
very calm very composed that's still the
case now now we know you taught him for
a couple of years but then you pass them
on off on to another famous trainer
Mehran share tell us about that collide
operation and what that bad boy through
well Marin and I work together and many
things with similar programs are
together we same classrooms
mehran is one of the world's great chess
coaches that people aren't familiar with
him he's a terrific trainer and he's had
many champions he's brought to the
forefront and developed nicely and you
know I work together very well so it was
the transition from me to me Ron
generally when I have a gifted kid I try
to take him to about him or heart to
about 1800 and then we find someone else
I don't think you should have the same
teacher forever I've said everything I
had to say at that point and it was time
for some new ideas Iran certainly
supplied them what was Bobby when you
work with him well first gave him
lessons late 5 so just about the age of
8 maybe a couple of months of 8 but
already he was working with new rock
pillars Reggie how many Ronald takes me
I think he tried to take at least two
sessions a week and what we worked on we
worked on several things a rook and
pointin things a lot efficient Islam
it's pretty obvious there was a big
crushing but by liszt hittin tactics and
stratagems in it and we kind of worked
through that we also play through the
game collections of aliens authentic
dishes fixing memorable and we looked at
the games of the spiral Karpov Korchnoi
quite heavily play a little bit favorite
thing to do was it was he like all about
Bruce when do I get to play you in blitz
or was he like really into the tactics
wait what did he look forward to the
most about the lessons of you well I
think he liked the the tactics and he
had of always doing his head and he
wasn't even touched a piece it was wrong
even if you were right the way I
approached it and he was a very fine
analyst he could hold all kinds of
conflict
intricate positions in his mind and I
think you can see that now you can work
through really tricky situations with a
clear vision that it's so impressive I
think it started there in some of those
early sessions what I also think he had
it in him
what you mentioned is something that
I've noticed with some of the young
players I've worked with actually the
older ones that I tell them to go back
is how you worked on the classics now in
the history of chess and Fabi has made
some statements that has shown that he
knows the classics he knows the old
games the old the whole world champions
that the client you just listed Fisher
and Alekhine and Bob Vinick he you must
have routed him right away in the good
stuff yeah the main idea today started
there many of those games and I think
it's very important I think young
talents do they tend to neglect those
paradigms I think that's a mistake I'm
not really all have the same chess
culture that many many people did in the
past on the other hand they have great
tools it's hard to deny that at the top
now players seem to be stronger you know
twenty eight hundred plus players right
but Carlsen in Carolina or well
especially Carlsen is very famous for
being obsessed with the classics in
chess history and not only knowing the
games but having the memorise down to
the date in place right yeah well it's
not easy to be world champion these days
which you are very much involved in the
other great American matchup Fisher
versus Spassky you are doing coke
commentary back in the day in 1972 if
that's not going to tell your age brews
they're trouble right there tell us what
it was like the fever pitch it was in 72
and how you first became a star because
of doing commentary on that match along
with of course Shelby London well Shelby
was the anchor he was he was great none
of us would TV
it was Shelby Ed Martin Edna's Eugene
Meyer myself and a few others none of us
had any experience with television at
all and I think that made it a very
appealing show we all make mistakes it
was nothing like your show is now well
you have so much experience and
[Music]
supportive technology and stuff
we were bare-bones you know a demo board
shall be up there moving the pieces and
they went to the hilarious moments yeah
it was live television things couldn't
be edited out it was all very I went
into Bruce well what was that yes it was
all very authentic oh yeah very much so
hmm we can make plenty of mistakes right
I'm saying you're giving a line for
white when it was really black or
whatever that kind of thing happens a
lot I wasn't actually on screen much was
Shelby was the main one on and he did a
fantastic job
it was really something there was some
interesting incidents if I recall they
had rasa-lila on one day and it was
quite clear he was inebriated Nicholas
Rossi lemo Grand Master whose variation
was played yesterday in fact that's
exactly right that's why I mention it
you rustling was brilliant
but he had been drinking too much okay
shall be asked him some question about
the position and he went on he said this
position is interesting it reminds me of
a game played by Yugoslavia whose name
begins with an M he could not it sounds
like we couldn't come on the air doing
that's the pusher yeah sir have you been
enumerated in America
but Bloody Mary is the question here you
you know we need we see this the the big
press following that we're getting now
all the press people that wanted press
passes for this match do you see this as
anything like vicious baski tell us what
that was like
well course that was front-page New York
Times coverage every day and also was
was on the news that was no-shows
especially after the second game Fischer
had forfeited and supposedly the
Secretary of State Kissinger had to
intervene whether or not it's true what
seems to be true so there was a lot of
attention people are very excited about
Fischer was the Cold War the raw boned
American against the Soviet army of
experts
it was just tremendous attention because
of that what the Bobby Fischer's was an
incredibly exciting personality in the
public's eyes you knew a mother in
private are like that it was just a guy
no do you see lien guys do you see this
as having any equivalencies between then
and now you do you feel like it could we
could have the same explosion in chess
in the United States if Bobby wins as we
had been when Fischer won it's possible
certainly there'll be great attention
from indian-american taking the title
and he's such a deserving young man he's
really worked for this he's a really
good guy
I think we'd represent the title very
well and could be an American Hero
so yeah it's possible I thought rival
the fischer time but it will be very
significant and I can see you just
really developing even more greatly
because of it never surprised you about
Bobby and his career
any kind of thing that shocked you about
his path well probably I always do
interview a great talent capable of
wonderful achievements I think you when
he had that great run at the sinkhole
Cup right was a 2014 that was yes I was
truly remarkable and very exciting and
that certainly turned to all our heads
Wow I mean I knew him to be amazing but
wow that was a WoW moment
and finally Bruce let me ask you this
question on a personal note knowing that
you were the first trainer of somebody
who becomes a challenger to the world
championship title I mean any trainer
has got to think that that says
absolutely a stunning thing how does it
feel for you to know that you started it
all for this young man I certainly feel
very good that I had been a part of his
early life there were other teachers
they all deserve credit as well when I
tried to give him was simply my love for
the game and he did all the rest but
certainly I'm very very happy for him I
had one other really happy moments I
mean maybe I'll have another one
hopefully at the end of this match when
Fischer won the championship that that
21st game I don't think I was ever
happier for another human being who
wasn't related to me and that day I
really felt that some kind of great
justice had been had been done I'm
hoping to experience something similar
to that here
well said Bruce and of course being
modest you have written so many books
train so many champions certainly one of
the great American stories what you have
contributed to chess in the United
States and a great friend as well thank
you so much for joining us and we'll all
be happy to if Bobby can pull this one
out thanks Bruce Thank You Maurice
Jennifer yes but be well thank you you
too Bruce I think that Bruce is really
one of the pioneers of this idea that
chess it's not just about chance that
it's about spatial reasoning eye
coordination the general intelligence
approach not just for raising champions
like Fabiano but just for raising more
intelligent and productive members of
society agreed all around no seriously
you're absolutely right there's really a
feeling of getting into know the person
and building them up from you know
positive reinforcement confidence and
everything you know as I was listening
to Bruce speak as the same thought that
I had about Magnus kind of went through
my head yeah there is an amazing thing
about fabbi that is just so unique and
that is this idea that they just kept
going up and up and up maybe a little
bit of plateauing with most form for
both Magnus and for fabbi they just kept
rising like a meteor there was no
massive fall off you know a lot of my
junior players you know we had thrills
and spills girl or I mean we would you
won tournament we could gain rate 50
rating points another tournament we
might lose 50 rating points we don't see
that down swings there's been so many
mainstream articles out these last
couple weeks I can't remember which one
it was but in one he was quoted as
saying how important it is to study and
work hard even when you're winning yeah
and I think that that's the missing
ingredient that a lot of players well
how are you gonna celebrate the same
field cup are you just gonna go on a
vacation to volley for a few weeks write
themselves some slack
I think that's part of the way that
these guys stay at the top they're never
satisfied
even if they even if they're winning
even if they're number one in the world
even if they're having the best year
ever he keeps pushing how could I have
played it better actually how can I get
even better right that's I think what
elite players constantly are trying to
do is there's truth seekers they're
trying to look at for example today's
game and I'd like to get back to the
today's match for just a second if I can
Maurice because something obviously went
wrong for Magnus
where was the novelty in this game and
where did where did things go wrong as
white you're not supposed to end up a
pawn down and a rook Infante ending
right I mean we were saying okay
Geoffrey not Geoffrey Gregory CAI Donna
I've told you that the positions equal
it's not supposed to be worse for white
so where did things fall off the rails
today for Magnus well the question is
definitely going to be that moment that
not that move that was played not
frequently seen rook to d8 this move
that's supposed to be challenged as
Jessie cry said GM Jessie cry who's a
grandmaster in residence of the club now
said Knight d2 is the question mark
what do you do after Knight d2 white is
carrying out this maneuver to get the
knight over to b3 also threatening to
move b4 in many positions and that's
supposed to be the critical way to play
against rook d8 rook gates not supposed
to make any real progress in this
position so 92 is the big question mark
when he played the move Bishop to deep
Bishop to e2 instead suddenly 94
appeared on the board and now White has
to be very careful in fact he castles
and allowed his pawns to be split this
became a permanent feature in the
position did not change despite anything
that happened next we can make several
moving moves on Yossi Magnus was not
able to alter the pawn structure and
look again his pawns were further split
although they this pawn now came to the
square and after this trade we saw this
endgame and the bad pawns so the
critical moment was that moment when d8
happened and he did not question the
move ended up in a bad part formation
Knight again
92 it and for all
the things that it does Knight d2 also
stops a knife from going to e4 as well
so that's been the critical move for
years and years and years the fact that
Magnus did not first of all the fact
that rook d8 appeared on the board at
all means
Fabi has some special preparation going
and the fact that he did employ the move
Knight d2 shows white not only didn't
get an advantage but he even got a
little tiny disadvantage as well so
that's the critical moment that right
now Magnus is trainer mangas the seconds
are looking at and saying why didn't you
play 92 okay we get why you didn't play
but if he plays this again let's go
check to see if this is right what he
did exactly so essentially you're saying
as a consequence of that opening misstep
by Magnus not taking up the challenge
with 92 he found himself actually
slightly worse due to his pawn structure
and then he ended up having a rearguard
action of I've got to draw the game I'm
not sure that the MOOC that not playing
Knight d2 I mean obviously like it's
just a d3 for example the move Bishop to
e2 though is one that says I'm not gonna
do anything to bother black okay right
I'm just gonna try to castle right
that's the kind of move you make when
you're afraid of preparation look at it
you start going oh I don't wanna get
caught by something you know what let me
just get out of the middle and so you
just put this up you two on the boards I
got I just got to get out of the middle
right that's it all right
and that's what this is this boo says
I've already developed a piece I'm gonna
move it twice I'm still caught in the
middle of the board with my king but I
am starting to make some consequential
threats against the position Knight b3
is one grateful is in the position b4 is
another idea that's in the position I've
dealt with this pin along this diagonal
I shut down anything like 94 takes is as
ridiculous because something will take
on c4 like an eye trouble tempo with
tempo so 92 is absolutely the critical
move and but the moment where d8
appeared on the board his the alarms
went off in his head and he either I'm
sure he's thinking oh of course I know
Knight d2 is the move but if I play it
I'm walking right
- this guy's preparation that he's been
doing for months and he could be
literally months that that Bobby has had
this in his back pocket waiting to drop
the bomb on some twenty eight hundred
and it happened to be Magnus staring in
front of him and he said okay I dare you
to play the main line because I am
well-prepared against it
so this is where we're gonna ask all the
questions and Jesse Christ said it
bluntly he said this is a bluff he
doesn't believe it I bet you he doesn't
play it again so we will wonder what
drama will happen with two days from now
in Game four if we will see this board
position again
that is when matches start to get
intriguing as people start shooting at
your openings Thank You Maurice and we
have one of our favorite people in the
world Jennifer on the line that's right
from London we have a wreck Singh field
the founder and president of a st. Louis
chess club to give us some insight into
the atmosphere in London hello Rex you
folks are just too kind it's nice to
call you from the mother country so the
atmosphere I sent you an email Jennifer
you'll get it shortly I think the
atmosphere is electric the place where
they have it is it's been pretty well
thought out the main hall for the
visitors to sit and look hasn't been too
well thought out the benches are just
benches there's no chairs the fact but
they've done a very good job of
sheltering the playing area from the
street noise you cannot hear any street
noise yes so that's axial and they have
a lot of side rooms for the media for
people to watch the presentations etc
are you getting accosted for your
autograph for the sink you'll cut books
right oh my goodness yes - it's
ridiculous in the email I sent Jennifer
I said I got waylaid today by seven
foreign journalists what - from Holland
- from Holland because they said one
said well you gave an interview to
channel two so now we want to do what so
I'm getting involved in these you know
internecine conflict not in Holland in
Norway I'm sorry
and then Germany and Yugoslavia also a
lot of seven of them today well we'll
keep your neutrality racks remember you
know we just want to see good games good
fights maybe
and Rex of course you know that your
huge Fabi fan you've done so much to
promote chess in the country that made
it attractive for him to come back and
not only moved it to the United States
but also to st. Louis so I don't expect
you to be objective but that said what
do you think so far what's the feel from
the Fabia the Magnus camp who's gonna
win this match well everybody I got to
tell you just listening to the the
gossip and small conversations going on
all over the place people were very
impressed with Fabiano today now someone
said this guy's just reeling off his bow
he said man he was ready for Magnus and
I think it's pretty safe to say that's
true and so the feeling is electric
there's a lot of different rooms where
you can cue the commentary from Judit
Polgar and some blonde that's with her
but of course yeah anyway yeah right
yeah I won't say anything on the air but
it's nothing like the great commentary
that you people do I can only thank you
so much you guys are absolutely
brilliant wonderful studios and
silverback you know that really brings
this show to the next level I believe
yeah how about yourself Rex you you
you're there with a group of spectators
how big is the how big of the crowds I
would say in the main viewing area the
main room to view it it's probably 200
people that's about all it holds and
then there are a bunch of side rooms for
media and other people viewing on
screens probably cumulatively I'd be
surprised that that's more than 150 okay
so you're looking at 350 yeah I thought
it might be bigger but all in all I
think they've done a good job we're
learning a lot of when we get ready to
have one of these in st. Louis
understand exactly what we have to do
and where we can improve it's a pleasure
being here and I really enjoyed my
Reese's comparison to Bobby Fischer I
think that comparison is not only
appropriate but it's inevitable
because it really in some ways is the
precursor to a match like this right you
know Rex it's like you read my mind
because I was jumped dying to jump in to
ask that question you of course were a
fan at that time in 72 compared that to
now how does that feel well you know it
it's hard to compare because of course
we had that wonderful thing going called
Cold War and that created an amazing
backdrop to an almost impossible kind of
situation alone America and basically by
himself without much help from others
against Soviet who has helped from all
over the universe and the lone American
crews victorious and death it was
symbolic of what people were looking for
in the Cold War as well but the media
hype then certainly exceeds what we're
getting right now although the media
hype is really picking up I would say
mmm but with Fischer it was front-page
news I heard your interview with bruce
pandolfini and he's right it was not
just front-page news with the New York
Times it's front-page news with
everybody is that every newspaper and
they're publishing the scores of the
games every day I lived in Chicago and
walking home to the station each night
Marshall Field store a very upscale
department store at the final position
of the game that they set up in the
window it was just crazy right now
there's a great infrastructure for chess
I wasn't around in but I I think you
know with millions of people playing
online on chess calmly chess with the
st. Louis chess club being the capital
of chess according to Garry Kasparov not
just in the States but in the world u.s.
chess I mean you've got a lot of
infrastructure now that you might not
have have been so yes maybe oh
absolutely yeah but there's more for
people who love chess because of this to
do right
oh yeah there's certainly many many more
chess players hundreds of times more
actively playing in the world today than
back then just because of changes in
population but also as Jennifer said
because of changes in technology exactly
that's a big assist in that regard and a
lot of people came up everybody seems to
be aware of thing was they were very
kind in all their compliments and things
using all of that it was so it was kind
of nice to be recognized that the world
seems to be aware of what we're doing
there in a few three and so it's all
wonderful well I'm glad you're getting
the accolades use you and Jeanne so
properly deserve because frankly Rex
when I go to events like the Chess
Olympiad I get a lot of people coming up
to me and saying wow what you do and
your show at st. Louis is so great and
all my students this and blah blah blah
I mean all of that credibly rewarding
yeah really
and I'm glad you're getting it it's
deserved it shows we're making a huge
impact and you guys are making a huge
impact but you know when you have the
three best commentators in the world
what do you expect I am returning to the
colonies tomorrow the colonies are
expecting it's great to have you on the
show I'm sure we're gonna be hearing
from you more when you're here in st.
Louis yes absolutely
don't Bobby okay absolutely go father
thank you so much folks well that was a
special treat well Rex Rex loves us so
much normally he'd be off to dinner in
London at this point of the day that's
right well it of course it's great to
hear from Rex who is of course there
with his was his wife dr. Jeanne
Sinquefield who he founded the club with
as well as joy Bray the general manager
of the club and you know you know I had
forgotten that Ian wrote about that but
Ian echoed Rex's thoughts about how the
conditions might not be that good for
the media but they're really good for
the players yeah meaning that the
quietude of doing all that they're very
well that it's really beautiful the way
that you can see the players and it's
also beautiful how they're also
sheltered from the fanfare so they
you're able to see them but they're not
able to hear you so that they made that
set up really better than others in the
past and Ric certainly echo that I also
heard good things about
the commentary room that it's kind of
small but that people are really
enjoying it and that Woody Harrelson
actually joined Ana ruled off and Judit
Polgar in the comment in the commentary
room celebrities involved in chess is
always great of course
oh no it's absolutely marvelous and
woody actually hid its visited quite a
number of chess events including Garry
Kasparov when he was playing against Yan
Tim on in Prague many many years ago
maurice jump in here with your thoughts
about things so far well this has just
been such a great match and I love when
we start talking about the history of
the World Championships because we have
had such great champions throughout
history and the youngsters players young
and old should definitely go back to
look at your classics look at those
great players who have paved the way for
the modern era we said it you heard
bruce pandolfini say it he taught Fabi
the classics right away he was going
over the great players of the past and
those are names that have shown the way
the paradigm I like the way he used that
word they were the paradigms for today
they showed us certain things about
chess that only those great geniuses can
come up with and so we've done a number
of fireside chats that we're going to
begin today we're gonna begin one of the
features today and we're gonna start
with the very first official world
champion will hem Steinitz and his reign
and also the player who eventually
defeated him please take a look as we go
to break and enjoy guys the world
championships have been so much fun
throughout history we've had these great
champions and I really liked Steines his
contribution to chess you know when I
read about Steinitz and I was a ninth of
13 children grew up in poverty to
actually become the world champion is
something pretty spectacular the first
official world champion right yeah right
well and that's really bugs me a lot
because I grew up with Paul Morphy let
me be clear I thought that guy's games
were brilliant
the 1850 there's no question this guy
was dominant player oh no question
1860 Stein its yeah Anderson those guys
are really doing it but why isn't there
a World Championship why isn't there an
official World Championship we have to
wait till 1886
well they hadn't arranged it yet they
hadn't set it up there was no
organization in fact that was the age of
the private World Championships and the
fact was that Steines had dominated
everybody he'd won something like 27 out
of 29 matches beating Anderson and
Blackburn and Byrd he's like I showed
I'm the man so he says I'm the world
champion but then super torch shows up
well then he got a rise evany he got
into writing into math and so he kind of
slipped a little bit people began
questioning his dominance well he wasn't
playing so much because he was busy
writing over there you go super tour
shows up and he starts playing and he
starts dominating and suddenly both of
them are saying well I'm the best so
finally in 1886 they come to an
agreement I mean that's what's happening
if you look at these like negotiations
and like how everything was up for
debate because it was a first world
championship from the time control to
the prize fund to the rules and of
course what fascinates me as the rules
are so different than they are now in
that there were so many decisive games
back in those days that you could say
the first to win eight games not a
problem or ten game or the problem the
fact is those matches for example that
one the first one sign-in Zoo Couture
they finally come to an agreement if I
only saw were gonna do it they played in
the US which was awesome they started in
New York and of course my home town so
awesome still they come to st. Louis but
but they start with victories nine eight
hits him in the first and in Zook retort
more men more games in a row right and
it's like what you don't see that these
days for games that are all losing and
you still don't win them out well
signage turn it around here and st.
Louis right that's exact and then it
finishes up in New Orleans so now we got
stats he's the world champion and then
how do you challenge the guy well this
is so that you've got to you got to put
up bids and you guys can raise the money
yourself
exactly in the world champion is saying
if you don't come up with this kind of
dough this a month you're not gonna
challenge me and people I'm not gonna
accept the chapel can you imagine these
days if Carlson said nah
Fabio unless you come up with two three
mil you can't challenge yeah but you
know before we before we go on to Alaska
I did want to point out how how crazy it
is that Steinitz
began his championship victory here in
st. Louis and I say that because in New
York he kind of got it squashed right so
in history we think of st. Louis as the
turning board worst Dinitz became the
champion right and actually this year in
the Sinquefield Cup we honored that
occasion by putting a plaque at the
venue and you officiated at unfurled the
banner that huge banner yeah you took a
lot of days by the way yeah after they
finished the st. Louis leg before they
end up going to New Orleans took
something like 12 days and apparently
they played whist I played cards in the
same place where they were waiting is
just hanging out playing card hey that
sounds like Carlson in Carolina you're
going too far too fast but Steinitz
becomes the first official world
champion but beyond that he becomes like
the first chess scientist he introduces
the idea that really there's something
much more about the game and that you
can take a very scientific approach to
numerous positions especially technical
positions I really give that guy a lot
of credit for two bishops versus Bishop
and Knight endings Steinitz man he
showed how to win those types of endings
well he visited Mar considered the
father of positional chess as a matter
of fact and all those principles that he
brought out he's a little quirky very
coarse being in the middle of the board
in a lot of positions now in those Kings
gambit positions where he's King is on
but I moved three or four right
but his defensive skills he showed us a
different level that you had to prepare
your attacks away from the Romantic Age
but then he loses to his ultimate
students a guy who gives him all the
respect in the world in manualized
exactly and we have the period of
Immanuel Alaska I want to be longest
world champion ever held the World
Championship the longest and he just did
amazing he it was sort of like he rose
to the occasion whenever ever there was
occasion
and I'm thinking particularly about a
New Yorker Frank Marshall oh he killed
Marshall
but the reason and how and the why that
he killed him goes to show who Manuel
Alaska was and the story is I don't know
if his myth but the story is Marshall
loses too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in chess
world championship edition as we have
two draws my brother Greg shall hobby
tweeted that he's enjoying the world
championship of drawing on down or
offended yeah so far what then yes
take your lessons Greg when you can you
got to learn those being a pawn down how
disabled yes / freeze but you say to
Craig a long time there you have it
everything old is new again
there you go I actually I'm still
reflecting on the conversation interview
we had with bruce pandolfini where he
was teaching his young protégé Fabiano
to fight like Botvinnik and i was
thinking well when I was a kid I was
growing up I wanted to learn how to kick
like Mark Spitz Mark Spitz was the
famous swimmer who won seven gold medals
in a single Olympiad so I wanted to
learn to kick like Mark Spitz and I and
and Fabiana learned how to fight like
Botvinnik
and other generations of Americans only
wanted to be like Mike how about you
Maurice did you have something in your
chest up ringing that was your
wellspring of chest ranked fight like
Michael tall no no fight like you came
out of Brooklyn I grew up in Brownsville
Brooklyn and we had a phrase never ran
never will never ray or never will write
never and never will you meet somebody
from Brownsville if they don't know that
they're not from Brownsville right never
ran never will be k all the way so there
you go we grew up fighting chess tough
but hey if I like by vinik sounds like a
good one okay you guys always going to
that guy that guy was tough absolutely
and we have guys were playing like
Botvinnik right now one particular
gentleman dig Lauren who broke tall's
record of well some say it's not quite a
record 95 straight games without a loss
dig Lauren is now over
your games as we speak playing right now
in the shinjin chess masters I mean they
booked every single important chess
tournament ever it looks like right now
during the World Chess Championships we
saw the Women's World Championship well
we've seen the winter chess classic a
and B here
now the Shenzhen chess masters and look
at those names ding Lauren you young ye
his countrymen who is now in the top ten
in the world you may not know that name
too well but no it is now above a lot of
names that we know like Nakamura and
Aronian he is now one of the top 10
players on the planet you see they're
curious playing in the event as well as
Maxine vascular grabs two superstars of
chess Rattus la vie to check who just
won isle of man against a bunch of
gangsters
he is now in tied as you said ty'
therefore third is not quite the right
way of putting that he's actually tied
for fifth place and Nikita Petukhov
another top 2700 player from Russia
strong players and pick teams everywhere
in that event this kind of event you pay
attention to if nothing else was going
on oh there's this thing called World
Chess Championships by right yeah that's
just how strong that event is and at the
same time we also have Tata Steel India
going on and it's just names like
Nakamura Aronian who are tied for first
place right now you got oh yeah well
monster five-time champion world
champion that is very strong players
playing right now it's a very busy chess
schedule and of course the Women's World
Championship going on as we speak with
brackets bracketology we got it study
and as you guys your bracket been busted
well I would certainly have Julian in
mind right now as she has moved on to
the round of 8 but look at all those
tied matches that says playoffs that's
right
playoffs tomorrow gonna be seed this
playoffs tomorrow it'll be a rest day
those of you who can watch definitely
you want to be
there because most choke animals to
check has moved on as well we're uh
sorry Maria mr. Chuck has moved on as
well her sister and uh still in a death
fight against F ANOVA so all these are
tied amazing exciting chess you don't
even get a chance to rest because all
these tournaments will be going on not
just the Women's World Championship but
all the others we mentioned so if you
feel like oh I can't watch the World
Championship hey there's a lot of stuff
to catch up on right now in the world of
chess that's right the Women's World
Championship starts at 5 a.m. Eastern
Time you who are worse not only up and
maybe still up from Saturday night
especially the further west you are the
earlier it is right that's right
California you know you wake up at 2
a.m. and there you go and you know
actually the the Women's World
Championship started out with like a
real star-studded list of commentators
but people talking about how ironic it
was that it was all men
exactly that was my thing I was
hilarious it was all men in the Women's
World Championship and then in the the
official World Championship it was too
titled female player exactly yeah and I
am in a GM and that but apparently a
female has joined the Women's World
Championship team well somebody who's
played against some of the players and
olympiade sure so who's your pick though
because of course we I didn't make you
guys pick who's gonna ladies and because
we are on Team Bobby right you know we
know it's a very close match technically
yeah but none of us are gonna not gonna
have to draw straws to see who has a big
Magnus that's unfair yeah right so in
the Women's World Championship though we
have no Americans in the race who's your
pick up well it's really tough to vote
against the Chinese ladies they have
been doing so extremely well whether it
be in the team competitions like the
Olympiad and the World Team
Championships or it's the individuals in
the match play and the knockouts so you
know if you say is you and
June yeah sure but I think it's gonna be
a Chinese lady I'm just not a hundred
percent sure it's gonna be you and June
so in a sense I'm hedging my bets but
now there are down to the Elite okay
that's fair I swear I I got it I got a
group you got a group well one though
listen let's get let's back up you've
got to pick one so I won't i won't go go
with the group of Chinese ladies
described it right Jew engine did you
see what she had to do with the Olympia
for China to win the gold oh yes Kosta
nuke that was amazing I mean this woman
has so much heart there's a reason why
currently the champion okay you might
say we find it not playing the cycle and
all that refine she can't control that
but what she can control she shows so
much heart by the way in order to win
her title in her match she had to play
against her own country woman that [ __ ]
was down in that match right and so that
was a slugfest as well she shows
incredible heart and for her heart she's
such a mild-mannered lady in the person
when you chat with her but in terms of
her heart the fire the dot desired the
willpower she's incredible and she's
showing that excellent play and also
that steely determination so she is an
easy pick I mean obviously an easy pick
is also the second ranked player in the
competition right that said the most
jokes I mean they're their powerhouses
there's a bunch of them in this
tournament of course a bunch of us that
is players that you could win this and
former world champions still in it and
by the way you said that the Chinese
ladies you're you're only down to I have
to go with um Jun yeah so that's why the
Moses Turks in the Giants not fair to
you to have made that bet maybe earlier
in the competition but right now the
better well maybe maybe it's due when
Joe and Jenn doesn't have the advantage
over them no clear advantage over
because there's what there one of them
is in tiebreak and one of them is
already through in both cases Maria
musici gets through you when June is
true on I have to play a playoff right
and that's exciting the playoffs
Lea team GU also has to play a tie-break
against the veteran of the field
gaya mova 46 years old still in there
fighting that's ahead of costume you cuz
I think of costume you because like a
forever child she's 33 really because
she's been like a world champion when
she was so yeah anyone like she won like
the second place I think when she was
like 16 or 17 yeah she was so incredibly
media friendly back ten years ago and
since then she still does a lot of stuff
in the media but not to the same level
so that's why you think of it but no she
still here Wow okay yeah and another
ELISA gala though I have certainly
remember her she visited Seattle back in
the day another player who visits an
American wife used to be used to a that
there is a red another player who visits
the United States a lot is you in June
she's played in the winter class one of
the the classic tournaments here in
chess club
she's also played in the Chicago open I
think all I think women playing chess
are so beautiful because you really get
there their face is um in deep thought
which is not something you see as much
from women in the media you usually see
women like kind of like smiling looking
at you rather than being totally
engrossed in their thoughts and I have
two wins you're just absolutely stunning
yeah she is a gorgeous gorgeous lady no
question about it you had a position for
us I think Marie said you were going to
jump in on it not really that this was
you were just kind of reading her in
continuing to keep to his knees yet to
keep his streak alive and the
controversy over the streak by the way
is many players give tal Vinod
for his ninety five straight wins but
circuit TV Yakov apparently has draw as
an unbeaten streak of 110 games and he
feels like he deserves a record and a
lot of people say well host sir gates of
Yakov we know him as a
strong grandmaster and now representing
holland but he feels like my streak
should count despite the fact that tal
may have had to play such incredible
players by the way tall streak included
something like 49 wins out of his 95
games while ding lauren has only so to
speak one somewhere in the 20s so he
doesn't even have 30 wins which makes
towels streak look a bit more impressive
but when you consider that digna ren is
playing against guys like magnus carlsen
and giri and and anon and nakamura and
all the top mummy-ji era of Fabiano
Caruana
tall inc I believe include a few open
tournaments that kind of patted his a
little bit not taking anything away from
top cuz he was he's my favorite player
of all time let's just make that clear
so ding Lorenz accomplishment is
absolutely incredible it's now vaulted
him to number four in the world he's
creeping up actually very close to being
number three on the planet behind the
top two players that are playing in this
world championship so just I think an
accomplishment that's incredible and the
fact that China won double gold of the
Olympiad that is both the open and the
women's side that just shows that
Chinese chess has arrived info and now
that you young years top 10 right it's
like oh man here they come we used to
have the Soviet hegemony over chess will
that happen as the Chinese invest more
and more in their rising players and
they also have a chess league simply one
of the biggest developments in the last
1012 years
absolutely and it is a simply a
phenomenal streak and until you actually
sit down and face these guys in a
one-on-one contest and hold your own I
got to tell you it's a it's a thrill to
play against a world champion and to
make a draw but then to go a hundred
games undefeated against the very very
best players in the world it's the same
now that is just that's tip your hat and
well done young people like they're
people like Carlson and Fabien okay I
don't know even come close to such a
street right
now Jennifer the upcoming is we're gonna
have a free day tomorrow because there's
really no game in London so Sunday
Funday well not so fun for those of you
who can't watch the World Championship
but will be back on Monday at the usual
time I mean well it's a get you excited
with our list of upcoming again is here
at today in chess we've got a Vladimir
Kramnik wow that's a special and in
federates dinner father Josh Waitzkin
author of searching for competition as
well as his newest book which was the
kind of a background of Magnus Carlson's
victory over Sergey in New York and he's
also he wrote mortal games about Larry
Kasparov as well okay vision on coming
in on by champion what to say huge
friend of the st. Louis chess club and
also Peter let go in November 19th Peter
and Vladimir I'm particularly excited
about because not people we've gotten a
chance to interview here before at the
same who is chess club and get their
perspective on this match and I love
what Peter Laker said out said to
Maurice Maurice reached out to Peter and
said would you join us Peter said I get
this questions from everybody and I
refuse every time but I like what you do
in st. Louis so I'll support you
oh yeah tomorrow that is Sunday November
11th and we'll be back on November 12 a
for Game three I said that game three
was gonna be the first decisive game of
the match Bobby with the white pieces so
let's bring it okay we could look
forward to that and there where we stand
this is where we stand going into that
third game we've got one point for Fabi
and one point for a Magnus with mirror
images of their games these two games
both times black fighting for the
victory but white house holding strong
to hold on to the draw and Maurice final
thoughts from you from these first two
pretty exciting games yes definitely
interesting games no grandmaster draws
these absolutely not these are the
battles of gladiators as they know how
important it is to games already done
tend to go will it require ten more
games or maybe even a tie-break
well the way they're going it looks like
we're gonna go the whole nine yards
tomorrow of course is Veterans Day here
in the United States certainly we want
to thank those veterans who make such a
tremendous contribution to this country
it's also a football day so you get your
chance to catch up on some football as
well that's all gonna be very exciting
but we're looking for it Game three on
Monday and it will be a thrill to be
sure so relax everybody enjoy the day
tomorrow
looking forward to seeing you with us
here on Monday Thank You Maurice and
good Sunday everyone indeed take care
bye bye now
[Music]